[Music]
hey
look it it's us again what a surprise
we're here we're tired
[Laughter]
here and we're tired we were at the
[ __ ] club last night yeah they had
the halloween edition of memento mori
it was all right it's kind of dead but
well it was kind of short notice
too like because we had one they usually
just do it once a month and we they did
one like at the beginning of the month
which was like the first one
that we'd had for like six months or
whatever yeah and then i just like a day
or two before
they were just kind of like hey we're
doing one for halloween week two so
yeah so we ended up going you can't get
up to the dj booth they got that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
walled off they don't like they don't
want you up there anymore
yeah i'm gonna have one my word with
like quit breathing on everybody god
damn it i have [ __ ]
your [ __ ] cooties yeah well
if you're there we're that worried about
it just stay the [ __ ] home
go the [ __ ] to sleep we were talking
about going to sleep last night we were
yeah that children's book yeah and then
i was like yeah because i had that was
like several years ago that came out
because samuel l jackson was like
reading it
i'm so i it just made me so happy that
like somebody actually wrote a
children's book called go the [ __ ] to
sleep because they were just like over
it
this is mostly lemon lemonade this is
very funny this is lemonade
with [ __ ] apple juice and just like
a tad of grape juice and taste that that
tastes just like grape juice it's
telling me
and it looks just like grape juice look
at i have to have two hands for this
[ __ ]
that's a man's cup it's just like grape
juice huh
i multiplied the grape juice i did some
jesus [ __ ]
multiplied the grape juice because that
you would never know that that
other fruit juice in it it just tastes
like grapes no i turned like a quarter
of a cup of grape juice into four cups
of [ __ ] grape juice
it's magic yeah just like dug him i
thought it was gonna come out like some
kind of punch but no
i just multiplied the game juice yeah
grape juice is just like crushes
all the other juices underneath yeah
that's okay i like grape juice
let's see how everybody is zach says tom
show
jenny that pic i just said i think
she'll laugh at it i i can't man i gotta
do this
also we were just talking about apropos
of nothing before we get to talking
about the movie
we were talking about how did we get
started talking about toilet seats
because all the [ __ ] toilet seats in
the goddamn house need to be replaced
and i i ordered one all right it went
through amazon and i've tried to put
that thing on there and that [ __ ]
toilet seat was about four inches too
[ __ ] small
so we got fat ass toilet seats
i was under the impression apparently
mistaken yeah
that all toilets were like a standard
size they were all the same
yeah you just like buy a [ __ ] toilet
seat i mean that's all i ever did every
other place i ever lived
no it's like the seat and the lid it's
it's not expensive it's like 20 bucks
no i know but it's like and i thought
they would all be
like the same size that said like
american standard but american standard
that's the [ __ ] 1930s
narrow ass [ __ ] narrow ass [ __ ]
before
corn syrup yeah i put that [ __ ] on there
and i was like i'll just put it i just
didn't even have to attach it i just
lay it on top there and go that ain't
gonna work
the standard ones are almost totally
round huh
and ours are kind of like [ __ ] long
and oval so like you could sit on them
and [ __ ] spread your legs and [ __ ]
like you're sitting on top of a damn
robo
fat people toilets i know it's like
that's what we got in here i didn't know
i just thought it was normal i did too i
didn't like realize that it was any
different it's not like i go around like
trying out different toilets everyone's
got to be replaced man they're starting
to [ __ ] wrinkle and the [ __ ]
finish of them is [ __ ] we didn't put
us together you know they've been here
since we got here since we got here
or something like that i don't miss the
humidity or what air conditioning gets
to them or just time i don't know
they don't last long i guess yeah i mean
they're just like made out of [ __ ]
yeah the hell they're making they're all
[ __ ] like custom colors and [ __ ]
they're all like beige and [ __ ] all
the
fancy [ __ ] remember back in the 70s when
everybody had to have like the fuzzy
tops on there
yeah and all toilets were white and that
was it and having the fuzzy top was a
dumb idea because you know like dude
well dudes be like stumbling into the
bathroom in the middle of the night his
naughty listen on it
[Laughter]
70s was not a hygienic time
and your mom and your grandma's always
hanging [ __ ] [ __ ] like [ __ ]
potholders from the handle on the damn
[ __ ]
on the handle of the [ __ ] oven oven
folding pretty towels on the oven should
get [ __ ] greasy and dirty you know
everybody wiping their hands on it
[ __ ] get rid of that [ __ ] man
that's some [ __ ] that they're filming
like their grandma [ __ ] did
[Laughter]
yeah everybody's mom is like a grandma
granny granny mentality
they put out [ __ ] little fancy shits
you know
little fancy [ __ ] little doilies and
just fancy shits yeah
look at that [ __ ] set out here what
is that like we're gonna put the little
glass the little glass chicken
now [ __ ] the chicken throw that [ __ ] out
of there
keep [ __ ] grandma had all that kind
of [ __ ] my mom's into that [ __ ]
oh isn't that so pretty no no get that
[ __ ] thing out
you know fancy [ __ ] you little fancy
shits
you know they think that that was like
real high-class stuff
[ __ ] just stuffed decorations in
every [ __ ] square inch of the goddamn
house
like they're the queen of england and
[ __ ] yeah
little bitty house and it's [ __ ]
stuff full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] dining room and all the little
service [ __ ] and the [ __ ] dining
cabinet for all the silverware
and for all the [ __ ] china for all
the parties they never have
nobody comes over to your house zach
said and i was just thinking about this
too remember fancy soap for guests you
weren't allowed to use it yeah yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] they were like little
moms would come up with us yeah like my
grandma had that little shell
they're like shells glass
to yeah everybody know that you're
[ __ ] rich and nobody and then they're
like oh well it's for guests but guests
would never use it because they're like
i don't think i'm supposed to use that
it's it's pretty and they were like
[ __ ] 50 cents
throw that [ __ ] away people know what
i'm talking about
they do yeah i'm hitting the ground
running i'm just talking [ __ ] now we got
to do the [ __ ] movie
we should yeah yeah i don't have time to
talk
about time
he's getting fussy we got to put him i'm
getting fussy goddammit
i think i need a nap too but uh yeah we
were out
we weren't up that late late but we
didn't go to bed until about maybe two
yeah it was like 130 or two and then
donald's on the bed getting crumbs
everywhere
man you're getting [ __ ] sesame seeds
everywhere just there's not that's
anything
and pookie jumps up and tries to eat
part of one of my french fries yeah and
then i ate the rest of it because i
don't care
i had just two big macs i didn't even
have french fries or anything i just go
through there and [ __ ] those dudes so
i can know me too they
recognized my voice so i caught the
drive through yeah and there's like
they're already here there's these
silly people again i just got two big
macs that was it
and i got it done with one of them and i
[ __ ] left that
paper box out it had the lettuce in the
bottom with the secret sauce and pookie
goes up there and smells that [ __ ] and
goes oh
no no she always has to check even
though she comes up on my desk
every single morning and has to like
stick her little face
she doesn't stick it all the way in
there but like in my coffee cup yeah
she's gonna know you do it and i'm like
that's coffee pookie it's coffee every
day you don't like coffee
because she always goes i wish she keeps
expecting it's going to be something
different like tuna juice i don't know
what that she knows what time the show
is too because when i got up to come in
here she goes oh it's show time she's
following me
then she gets bored while we're sitting
here she's like yeah cause she's like oh
you're not talking about talking
yeah it's all [ __ ] off bye but yeah
she'll probably come back in here she
probably still yelling at those lights
yeah
yeah stop it it's like what are you guys
laughing at humans are crazy
yeah we are kind of from their point of
view uh mark says this movie sounds
familiar is this the one where they
buried the people in the coffin box
alive yes it is uh at the end spoiler
alert
um somebody says watch eli i have seen
that i actually
i don't think we uh reviewed it though
for some reason i remember watching it
and i meant to review it and then we
didn't get around to it for whatever
reason but whatever
so this movie is the house's october
built
uh this is also on to be for free if you
want to like get into like the halloween
marathon watch along with tom and jenny
um this is actually this came out in
2014
and it is a found footage mockumentary
type of movie um directorial debut of
bobby rowe
and basically it follows like a group of
friends
who rent an rv and they're basically
going around the country
um trying to find like the most extreme
haunt
and during the course of that endeavor
they seem to run into a group
uh known as blue skeleton who kind of
like
stalk them and then like do some [ __ ]
up [ __ ]
to them at the end and like you don't
know if it's like really real or not
now i will say okay this is really
interesting because
one i thought i had seen this movie
before but then i was watching it and i
was like okay i've never seen this how
could that happen i thought i watched
like all the halloween movies last year
but i guess not
so so i watched it it's like i i'm not a
big found
footage fan i like mockumentaries um
but so this one i liked it but i didn't
love it
i mean i really like the conceit and i
like
that they um because i this
isn't one of those like ooh jump scare
like paranormal activity type movies
it's almost kind of like a road trip
movie and you feel like you're kind of
going along with them to all these like
haunted houses like around the country
like in the midwest and in texas and
stuff like that
and that's really cool like it made me
want to you know it made me want to like
do a road trip like this because it
looks like super fun
um i will say that one criticism i have
of the movie
is that um it's kind of muddy you can't
tell what's going on a lot of time
because like i said it's found
footage and they're like filming stuff
like inside of you know haunted houses
and stuff so it's like really hard to
see so it's like
people like popping out and screaming
and stuff and i feel like they didn't
spend enough time with the characters
um for you to get to know them um
so when [ __ ] started going sideways at
the end
you're almost it wasn't like that you
didn't care but it was just kind of like
um you know i wish i had gotten to know
them a little bit better so you could be
like more invested in like what was
happening to them i did like the idea of
like a weird group that run like an
extreme haunt like going to these like
ridiculous lengths to like [ __ ] find
you and give you this experience because
that's how
like they're at this one place and
there's like the creepy um
the creepy doll girl like the girl
that's on all the all the posters and
stuff
and they see her at the one place and
it's creepy but then like they're at
another haunt like 100 miles away
and they see that same girl and they're
like what the [ __ ] is going on so it's
like these people that are like
seem to be like stalking them across the
country so i really liked that aspect of
it
now you know what's interesting though
is that
i was just gonna say like when i watched
this movie i was like oh it's fine it's
like you know for a found footage movie
it's
good i like the conceit it's not scary
but it's kind of like that's not
really what it's trying to do um it's
kind of like a celebration of
haunt culture and you know it's kind of
like a road trip like it's kind of like
an adventure and then there's like some
creepy [ __ ] going on at the end
but when i looked into the background
of how this movie got made and i also
watched
the sequel uh which is also on to be for
free like i watched that this morning
and it actually gave me a new
appreciation
for the first movie because
the thing about like there's a whole
[ __ ] story behind the house's october
bill like the dude that did it bobby
rowe i guess he was like a baseball
player or something like that but him
and his friend were like
really into horror movies and he's like
[ __ ] this i want to make horror movies
so he goes to film school
and they initially got the idea to do a
movie because they're like we want to do
like found footage
they've started working on it like
before found footage like got really
really like before paranormal activity
came out and like
you know it was just like a huge
explosion of them so he wanted to do
that he wanted to explore the urban
legend
which turned out to be true which we
talked about on one of our shows um
of you know the fun houses that have
like the real dead bodies in them or
like haunts that have real dead bodies
in them
so he started he's like so they started
doing like a um
a screenplay about uh these haunts
and then they came on the idea of like
let's do a road trip and we'll go to
these actual haunts and like interview
people like actually
and so they had a script but a lot of it
was like
improvised so they actually like hired a
bunch of their friends um
so they made the movie in 2011
the first time and it screened at a
bunch of uh you know festivals and stuff
and people were really into it
and like it's like some famous people
like rob zombie and [ __ ]
and so they ended up getting funding to
remake
the movie but like with a bigger budget
and like a slightly bigger crew
so they kind of like tweaked it a little
bit um
adding the blue skeleton uh aspect
because by then like the corpse thing
wasn't quite as
uh compelling and so they basically
remade the entire
movie using some of the footage from the
first one
so that's kind of why um the first movie
is sort of a little bit the quality of
it is like
variable because it was like shot at
different times
but like listening to the guys talk
about how like passionate they were
about this project they made this
[ __ ] movie like
twice over and they actually rented an
rv
they actually were their own crew they
actually went around the country to all
these haunts
and interviewed all these people for
real like the people that you see
interviewed in there it's totally real
um and didn't really tell them what to
say other than like throwing them like a
oh mention like you know this or that
but that's all
like the rest of the time they just let
them do whatever so i thought that was
really cool and then
when i watched the second one which is
um
it had about the same budget but it
looks a lot nicer
um because they had a they had a drone
and like you know [ __ ] like that like
all the same
actors came back all the same characters
came back and basically
what ends up happening in the second one
it's like a it's
exactly like continues from the end of
the first one because the first one like
ends on kind of a cliffhanger i'm not
going to spoil it but um
but the second one like picks up right
from that and then they kind of take it
at a different direction
and when you get to the end of the
second one it almost like
re-contextualizes the first one like in
kind of a cool way
so i will say that i actually liked the
second one
more than the first one even though i
seem to be alone in that opinion because
the first one like seemed to get like a
really big like response like it sold
out like i won all kind of awards like
it got all kind of like famous people
like on board with it
um want to produce it and everything and
um then when the second one came out
i feel like it didn't really get it got
like kind of shitty reviews
and i was like i thought that was very
strange because
i honestly liked the second one better
it was easier to watch
because you know the footage wasn't so
dark and like chaotic and everything so
it was easier to watch the footage was a
lot smoother a lot nicer looking
there was a lot more because these
actors are actual friends in real life
and have made this move you know have
been with these characters for so long
and are going by their real names um
there's like a there's an easy rapport
with them that they seem like real
friends because they are
and so you got to spend more time with
them in the second one and like actually
like
get a sense of their personalities and
things like that so i liked that about
the second one
um but a lot of people for whatever
reason like didn't like the second one i
don't know why i thought it was cool
but like i said seeing the second one
actually made me like the first one
more and you know i just really like
the whole story of like these indie
filmmakers who are so into like these
horror movies that they will just go to
like
amazing lengths like to make the [ __ ]
read badger's comment what did he say
this movie is on amazon in the uk but
under a different title
yeah i saw that it was called something
different like in some different
countries
houses of halloween how houses of
halloween is the british title
yeah and um the second one is actually
called even though in the u.s it's
called the house's october bill
2. um i think most other countries in
the world the second one is called
hellbent
which is the name of one of the houses
that they're going to like one of the
extreme haunts that they're going to
um so yeah this does has let have like
some different titles
but like i said they're both in the us
they're both on to be for free
um if you like found footage if you like
mockumentaries
um and you're interested in haunt
culture which i am because i even like
like documentaries about that because i
always thought it'd be like super fun to
like
produce one or like help put one on and
stuff
you know i i i don't like found footage
movies i don't either generally
uh but this one's okay um they just
don't pull me in as much as a
as a cinema you know what i mean that's
cinema what i call cinema you know i
mean where there's
shot composition and stuff and kind of
formatted i like it more like that
um but as far as as far as found footage
goes it was it was decent
yeah it's a d well it's doing something
different it's not you know what i mean
it's like i said it's not even it is a
horror movie but
it's mo it's more like a road trip movie
like we're going to go around and they
go
and it's cool because the first one they
kind of concentrate on
kind of traditional haunts like haunted
houses
um the second one i liked that they
tried to change it up
like the [ __ ] that they go around to
they did like a zombie 5k
run which was like outside like in this
at this big like firefighting
pavilion like with all these like broken
down buildings and stuff so that was
cool so you were
like running a race but you were trying
to like get away from zombies at the
same time
um so they had that they had like some
hayride type of [ __ ] they
had um like this big uh that
you know that big zombie bar crawl they
have in minneapolis so they used to have
it every year there was like 30
000 people there they had like the
[ __ ] the brain
how many brains can you eat like brain
tacos or something like that
and they even got like you know that
little japanese guy that wins every
single [ __ ] eating event
like he's just this tiny little he's
like 130 pounds or some [ __ ] he's like
this tiny little dude
and he he he wins like the nathan's hot
dogs he can eat like all this stuff
so they got him in the movie like he's
in there eating the brain tacos and he
wins of course
and uh [ __ ] like that but it's just i i
almost found
so i like that the second one like went
with more like
outdoor events and like more stuff that
happened in the daytime so you could
like kind of see what was going on
because then the first one
you know a lot of it when you go through
like a haunted house and they're just
guerrilla filmmaking i mean obviously
they have permission to like film inside
there
but it's dark and you can't really see
much of anything so it's just kind of
like you're stumbling around in the dark
like i guess like you're
really in there um so the second one you
could see what was going on a lot better
plus they had the drones so they had
like a lot more
like smooth footage and stuff um before
i forget everybody please hit the like
button hit the like button
hit that thumbs up hit the like button
yeah okay sophie said she did a zombie
haunted 5k run like that
it was outside in an orchard though and
in the daylight this one they did was in
the daylight too apparently it's a real
one it's in perry georgia
and um they do it on i guess there it's
this huge facility
that they use to train like firefighters
and cops and stuff so they have like an
area that's like all fallen down like an
earthquake
they have like an area that's flooded
like a hurricane they have like all this
other kind of [ __ ] so they can go it's
like a training facility
and one day a year the in the daytime
all these people come and run a race and
you can pay a little bit extra and you
get they dress you up like a zombie and
you gotta chase like all the runners and
like try to like tear their flags off
and stuff it's like really funny
so they had like some footage of that so
that was like really cool to see
like i think that was the best part of
these movies is like seeing like the
creativity of the people
that do these haunts um just the [ __ ]
they come up with like in their houses
and stuff so
in a way that was like actually cooler
than the the story that was going on
although i liked the story better in the
second one like i said
because it's sort of like
re-contextualized the first one but i
think a lot of people didn't like the
way it re-contextualized it maybe
but i thought it was i thought it was
clever apparently they're making another
one
i see everybody hitting the button go
ahead hit it again
all right so uh do you have anything
else you would like to add
mr thomas no i got [ __ ] i got it about
toilets or
man we got it again at the beginning of
the year not the beginning of the year
the beginning of the month
yeah yeah that's like really funny
because i couldn't believe that like you
said oh i ordered a new toilet seat for
the bathroom and then like it gets here
like it doesn't even
he says yeah the new ones are all kind
of oval yeah yeah
and so i thought that was the american
standard i did too
that is not the american standard the
american standard is a little bitty
round thing you wouldn't want to sit on
you have to kind of perform
[Laughter]
with like big old things of ass sticking
out on either side
i want the toilet out of idiocracy which
is that [ __ ] recliner
where the [ __ ] ball is you would want
that yeah do you know what when i saw
that and it was in the living room it
was in the dude's living room that's
what i'm saying
you would put it right in front of the
tv so you could just like sit down and
play video games and stuff you would
totally do that
you would totally do that i would no i
wouldn't it was just a good idea
you know what give you five years i bet
you will [ __ ] do that
yeah an idiocracy though it had it was
in front of his flat screen
in the living room and every time he'd
sit down he'd pull his pants down even
though he wasn't going to the bathroom
he just sat
and he got back up pull his pants and he
pulled him back down and he had a big
old [ __ ] popcorn bucket full of nacho
cheese
yeah he was just eating it with his with
his fingers yeah watching out my balls
yeah watching out my balls yeah that's
[ __ ] funny all right
okay so uh we're gonna wrap this up so
we can go take a nap
um because i'm really really really
tired and uh we'll be back tomorrow
talking about another halloween movie
which i'm gonna watch tonight which i've
actually seen before
um but i'm gonna watch it again because
it's been a year or two since i've seen
it so uh we'll see you guys
again tomorrow bye